how to start a new business in a new
field so I got a great question from one
of my newsletter readers love you guys
Mike who wrote in to say Evan what can I
do to start catfish farming grass Carter
farming and snail farming in Nigeria how
to raise the funds how do I get the
knowledge what website can i go to hope
reading from you soonest kind regards
mike okay Mike this is a great question
and i am not going to lie to you I don't
know anything about starting the
business in Nigeria I didn't even know
snail farming was an industry but it
doesn't matter here's why if you want to
get started in an industry this applies
anybody you want to start a new business
you want to get into a field that you
you have no experience in the best way
to do it is to model success you have a
goal that you want to accomplish and
maybe the people in your life you know
they don't support you maybe there's no
family member to guide you right when I
started my business I didn't have family
members who are entrepreneurs I had
nobody to look up to and say oh here's
how to do it instead of trying and
failing and trying family and trying and
failing which has two things of burns
all your resources it burns your time
and money but it also limits your time
right like you only have so much of a
window to make this thing happen in your
life that yours burning years making
this thing trying to get it to go and
doing all the wrong stuff right trial
and error is not the way to do it model
success find someone who's already done
this and model what worked for them
apply it to your business there's a few
ways to do it okay the first is to read
this is what I did my very first
business I read the stories of famous
entrepreneurs who I look up to and I
realized I'm not the first guy to try to
sell software that was my first company
not the first guy so I looked at Bill
Gates i looked at the founder of mcafee
up into it how they got started 0 to 1
million how do they do that because
that's what i want to replicate and i
learned their strategies and made it
work for my business and within a couple
months already started seeing results
okay so who
ever who's doing snail farming that you
can read up about learn their success
stories and apply it to your business
okay second is get a mentor find
somebody who has done this who may be
retired who's looking to give back who
has some experience who can help you
even if it's just once a month going for
coffee or lunch you're buying it right
just find a mentor to help you along
your way because again you're taking the
experience of someone who's been through
it who can choke out your path who who's
done all the mistakes and you're about
to make right I don't want you to go
take out a huge loan to start of snail
farm in Nigeria and it doesn't work out
for you man that's like debt for the
rest of your life get somebody who's
gone through it and give you experience
give you ideas you can bounce ideas off
of and a lot of times older people who
have gone through it they're willing to
give back man if you are curious if you
are showing that you're going to apply
their knowledge I love helping out and
give him back and entrepreneurs tend to
like to help other entrepreneurs but you
got to show that you're willing to
actually implement the advice and so
reach out and find people who have done
this and get their feedback it's really
important this helps save my business to
in the early days that first company had
a guy named John who was my mentor who
had built in Seoul technology companies
and he knew what to say and how to act
and who to talk to and it would have
taken me years and maybe I never would
have figured it out by myself but by
connecting with him boom he short kid in
my path to success and we were able to
build the company quickly and eventually
get acquired the third thing is get a
job and you might be singing a venir the
entrepreneur guy telling me to get a job
but yeah absolutely a lot of the most
successful entrepreneurs if you look at
their history they started with getting
experience working at a company and the
great thing about it is you're getting
paid to learn this is you're still
modeling success right go find whatever
the best snail farm is in Nigeria and
offer to work for them even if it's for
free but start to work for them right
ideally you're getting a part-time job
or even a full-time job because here
you're getting paid to make mistakes
they're paying you to learn and to make
mistakes so when you go in there you
know how the business works you know you
know how they make money you know
I metrics to look at to grow the company
you know who the clients are you know
how to run a business you made the
contacts you made your early failures
all the meanwhile getting paid to do
this it's like going to snail farming
university but instead of you pain
they're paying you so that when you're
ready to go and launch your business you
know exactly what to do you know who to
hire you know how you're going to sell
you know you know how you're not going
to make the mistakes you know how to get
the capital everything you need you've
already learned by working at that
company some model success for everybody
watching guys is so important you don't
know about an industry don't just
launched in and blow your energy and
your dollars and your time because it's
going to take you so long to figure it
out all on your own the e don't have to
come up with all the answers yourself
most of the challenges have already been
figured out by somebody you have to
leverage what everybody works in an ad
your spin to it that's the difference
that's the key you do that you'll take
off so much faster and have such a
bigger impact and make way more money
and be more fulfilled and happy and
having movement behind you so model
success find people who have done it in
books in mentors and job opportunities
learn from them apply their knowledge to
learn the business no one inside out
then launch your company and when you do
you'll hit the ground running and build
a massive Empire that you can be proud
of believe those you're watching I'd
love to hear if you've had a mentor
people who you've modeled success that
you've gone after and said I like that
person i'm going to research your store
and it made it work for you share it
below i'm curious and it's also going to
help inspire other people so please
leave a comment underneath you like this
video give it a thumbs up i love doing
these videos for you so please give it a
thumbs up and you want to see more
videos like this click on my face
subscribe to the channel thank you so
much i'll see you soon
you